hi I'm Evan Carmichael and welcome to
another video edition of ask Evan in
today's episode I'm going to answer
question from one of our readers Joey
who is in the network marketing business
and is having a hard time getting the
business off the ground so the question
here is my website is WVW online
entrepreneur skill calm the website is a
first posted by carbon copy pro Worman
I've been an affiliate for nine months
with without anything to show for it I'm
grateful for any assistance you can
offer to bail me out of these doldrums
thank you so I first glance at the
website it looks like a very generic
site I don't see anything personalized
around you so it's all kind of
promotional content which can be great
to get people to sign up but at first
what I think you want to do is try to
build a relationship with your readers
so I try to tell your story you haven't
had much success yet with the program
but maybe you could talk about why you
started why did you sign up for what was
the appeal what was the interest and
tell a little bit about you when were
you from and your background and people
like hearing that they want to see that
it's personal they like buying from a
person and not from you know a standard
corporation so I try to incorporate
those elements as much as you can in
beyond just having this static page
that's you know corporate promotional
material that stuff still has a place
and will help convert some of the people
over to wanna sign up but first I think
you need to build a relationship with
the people who are coming to the site
and make them get to know you a little
bit more before they're going to take
the next step to want to sign up and
move on the next thing I would try to do
is look for people in the organization
who have had success and try to model
their strategies so first I would look
in your upline and see if there's
anybody who's had tremendous success and
see what you might be able to copy from
them but generally with any network
marketing organization they have list of
who the most know successful people are
in the organization and quite often
those people are pretty open to wanting
to share
their success they've had success and
entrepreneurs are usually pretty open to
wanting to help other entrepreneurs who
are genuinely interested they don't want
to waste your time and give you a bunch
advice and then see that you don't do
anything with it but if you're genuinely
interested in wanting to build a
successful company then the you should
will really want to help you out so I
try to tap some of the top people in the
organization and see how they've done it
pick their brain and try to copy some of
those strategies as well the third thing
I recommend is trying to build a
following so I don't know how you're
relying on people getting to the site
right now but I would try to build up
the following through the website and
also through social media so people
become attached to you and when they
come out check out the site they're more
likely to want to sign up and go to the
next step so you could create a twitter
account and create a facebook account
you can start blogging and talk about
the things that you're really excited
about passionate about some of the
reasons why you started this business
and some resources that you find
interesting and helpful and exciting for
you and help motivate you and inspire
you all that kind of stuff is really
useful and you'll start building up an
audience of people who like hearing from
you and even if you're not promoting the
content you're saying hey is something I
found really interesting and exciting
and if there's enough of that useful
content out there then people will want
to start following you and they'll then
be curious about what you're up to and
they'll check out your site and the more
they like the content you're producing
the more likely to want to sign up as
much as they can so I focus on whatever
medium you find easiest so you know if
you'd like blogging if you're really
great at typing and creating great
content go with the blog if you're you
know not that great at typing but you
still want to get involved in the
written language then you go with no
Twitter if you're really great a video
it on YouTube combine all of them if you
can but try to start building the
following try to add a lot of value add
information so people want to follow you
they want to learn more about
you and the more likely to then sign up
and take that next step with you instead
of just having that static page so I
hope that helps I hope you can follow
some of those steps and get out of that
nine months slump and start building a
business for everybody else if you
enjoyed the video please give it a
thumbs up and we'll create more of them
and love to hear it constant feedback if
you want to leave a comment below and
stay tuned for the next episode
you
you